what um what kind of tunes do you listen
to what kind of music do you listen to
I'm into I'm into
so many different types of music I like
uh I mean my my all-time favorite bands
are Rage Against the Machine the Beasty
Boys and the Red Hot Chili Peppers um
but I listen to Everything I listen to
80s music listen to 70s music I listen
to uh rap I listen to what was your
walkout song Be You think if you were a
fighter oh
[__] there's so many good ones to choose
from I sort of lived vicariously through
the through the athletes over the last
you know however many years cuz I picked
a lot of the songs for a lot of these
guys to walk out to yeah do some of them
just not want to pick it some of them
don't even give a [__] what could care
less like they could die they're not
even going to know what music's on the
way there nope oh damn yeah most most of
them didn't even care in their early
days and yeah you can't die on it with
Hillary Duff when you're going to the
[__] War yeah no most of the music
that was picked back in the day was done
by me and um but the but but the walkout
song is important it's a big deal it's
one of the things that if if you're not
a big star already and the song comes on
and people connect with the song and
like it they're like oh who is this guy
it's a big deal yeah Bobby green I think
does it pretty well I notice he'll kind
of change his up and he brings so much
energy you know but I think you can feel
his energy when he's coming in uh porier
has that James
Brown you know some of these Fighters
come up with songs that I would never
dream of could be a cool walk-in song
and uh yeah the walk-in song is is a fun
but very important part of the the live
event so what do you think your walkout
song would be look can it just be the
cult sure I do the C I do the cult uh I
do the cult sheel Sanctuary um or listen
you know when you can never go wrong
with a walkout song ACDC yeah you never
go wrong with
ACDC I'm trying to think of an ACDC song
I'm a little Back in Black yeah For
Those About to Rock For Those About to
Rock oh that's the [__] my brother used
to beat the [__] out of me all music
exactly some good ass whooping music oh
I still I have a floating rib that was
originally not
floating uh because of half of Allison
Chain's second
album
CH Allison chain fan bro we would lose
bro one time I go over to Perry frell's
house right I relapsed first of all I
relapsed at a one-year-olds birthday
party so obviously I've had some tough
times but um I A friend of mine who's in
jail now I think but at the time he had
a child a friend of mine had a party at
Perry Ferrell's house because he had a
nice home and it was a one-year-old
birthday and I go in and I didn't know
who Perry farell was I listen to him you
know I just couldn't recognize him right
and then I'm just there's this dude kind
of just mumbling around by this big
bookcase and I go over there I'm [__]
talking to the dude about these
different books and ended up being him
uh anyway the story is anticlimactic but
yeah I met him at a one-year-old
birthday party and neither one of us
knew the child which I think also made
it weird and we talked about that a
little it's weird to be at a really
small kid's birthday and pretend that
that he's bigger or something right you
know um what is that Nick chenade oh
that's chenade yeah yeah yeah that that
that's that that's a good one you know
it was fascinating too because was a big
chenade big chenade fan and uh I
actually didn't go to my high school
10-year reunion because chenade o Conor
was playing at the Hard Rock I went to
see sheno Connor instead and um then to
meter and go through this whole thing
with Connor and she was such a
incredible performer and had such a
great voice and I think this kind of
goes to what you were talking about
about putting yourself out there you
know she ripped up that picture of the
Pope on Saturday Night Live that night
and she got [__] just attacked by
everybody I mean everybody just started
coming after her and she got beat on for
so long that she actually got to the
point where she would have terrible
anxiety when she would go out and try to
perform wow so leading up to that Connor
walk out it was uh we didn't know if it
was going to happen or not happen live
even though she was there and we had
done the deal with her to come but um
yeah I adored her she was a really good
person I liked her a lot and uh it's sad
to see her go but I was a huge shade fan
did you like give her a pep talk before
is there any kind of communication like
that 100% I absolutely
did
that